email is is fantastic because it
actually represents a host of bets of
computer science all converging and
interesting ways and I think there are
lots of computer science that's and the
simple act of sending an email the level
and amount of email that we deal with
something like 2.8 million emails per
second so just if you just think about
that number think of what that means
it's their motive email gets sent and
floors around the world all the time
when you write an email how does the
computer know it's a message and what
does it do with it what's great about
this example I think is that it shows
the ways in which computers deal with
complexity what's important because
there's so many email messages is that
it has to deal with those things very
very quickly so there's a standard for
email which splits email up a bunch of
it is header information and another
parts body so why is that important or
header is what the computer processes
body is the message that you read all
the fields that you see that say from to
date ID so you would say drum Tom - Bob
so that's the bet that passes for
addresses and looks at the parsing is
the way the computer looks for specific
spatial ones and special symbols so it
knows when it rains from : that's going
to be an address and to corns going to
be addressed that is a specific
character which says taking a new lane
and it knows that if there are two of
those that it's no a body and it knows
there will be a specific marker called
end-of-file marker at the end so it's
got a really simple way of finding
information and that simplicity makes it
very very fast all of this is what
called ASCII text it's all your min
readable and it only is those 128 a
rigid
characters that were used by computer
systems okay so this is understood by
all machines and human readable which
was really important in the early days
of these systems whenever they'd go
wrong you'd want to be able to read and
find out why so this has persisted as
the standard for send an email how does
that work though when you think about
some of the things that you send by
email how did your ball text how do you
send an image how did you send a picture
using this okay or how make you send
attachments using this computer science
does an awful lot of what's called
abstraction and extension and the way
you deal with that is you add on to this
an additional way of handling this so
currently this body is no interest at
all to a computer processing system the
introduced are we tagged in the header
that what was in the body could be
processed by the computer as well so
they developed the system called main
which is a multimedia extension and main
then signals that inside this body you
will actually have another layer of
encoding so when you deliver the message
something else can look and say that
message and then understand that what's
in there are pictures images fail
attachments as well and MAME has its own
language for doing that and for
describing that that itself is based
upon our previous system called uun code
which means UNIX to UNIX encoding which
is the way in which you'd actually take
and fails and represent them as
characters so margin your hard are
better for fail this would translate to
here and this would translate to see you
would then have a and C which you could
then translate back enter that binary
encoding so what happens and you encode
as it says begin details and and the
program knows that all that a ski that's
end there has to be read as ass
and then translate it to that raw text